could Alec Murdock get a new trial a new
motion filed by his defense teams lays
out some pretty damning evidence against
the Court's own clerk alleging jury
tampering
jurors must be free from outside
influences and must decide the case
solely on the evidence presented in the
courtroom we're breaking down the many
times Miss Becky allegedly misled and
even outright lied to jurors and the
court in the supposed pursuit of finding
Alec Murdoch guilty law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
thank you
and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber now one of the
biggest cases of the year and one of the
most infamous characters in True Crime
history could be starting all over again
Alec Murdoch's defense attorneys filed a
motion for a new trial citing jury
tampering the new filing points the
finger at the clerk of the court Rebecca
Hill known to many as Miss Becky they
accuse her of jury tampering the motion
claims that Hill instructed jurors that
Alec Murdock couldn't be trusted and was
likely guilty Alec Murdock was convicted
in March of this year for killing his
wife Maggie and Son Paul on their South
Carolina estate the ones trusted and
well-known attorney to stand in his own
defense proclaiming his love for Maggie
and Paul but after weeks of testimony
and evidence it took the jury only three
hours to convict him Murdoch is
currently serving life in prison but his
defense team hopes to turn all that
around with a new trial in their motion
dick harputlian and Jim Griffin provide
multiple examples of Miss Becky's
allegedly inappropriate behavior savior
the motion states that Rebecca Hill
instructed jurors not to be misled by
evidence presented in Mr Murdoch's
defense she told the jurors not to be
fooled by Mr Murdoch's testimony in his
own defense she also allegedly told a
juror not to question the fact that the
murder weapons have never been found and
even indicated to the jury that if they
didn't come back with a quick verdict
they'd all have to be taken to a a hotel
for the night even though no one brought
an overnight bag now Rebecca also went
on to write a Rebecca Hill went on to
write a book about the trial which was
released in August the attorney spoke in
front of the South Carolina court of
appeals on Tuesday and talked about
another strange move by the clerk
one of the things we heard was once the
jury went out
even though there were six smokers and
they were given smoke breaks during the
entire trial once the jury went out they
were told no more smoke breaks
no you're not you people that want
nicotine you're gonna have to get a
verdict first I mean it's that kind of
stuff now that indicates something and
The Quirk would be the one to
communicate that why
so uh a bunch of folks told us stuff
that appeared to be
inconsequential but in the total context
indicated to us uh that what we've put
in this petition about The Quirk uh is
credible um and based on sworn testimony
from two jurors and we interviewed a
third
my paralegal Holly Miller has given you
an affidavit or filed an affidavit on
what she told us a lot of these folks
just don't want to get involved but
they're going to be involved if we get a
hearing because each and every one of
them is going to have to testify in an
open court before you as to what
happened and what didn't happen
pretty unbelievable let's talk about it
join right now by my legal analysts my
co-host Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin
Brian will start with you reminds me a
little bit of the Scott Peterson case
what does the defense have to do in
order to get a new trial for Alec
Murdock so it's interesting in terms of
the presumption here because we're so
used to the presumption of innocence was
to prostitution and then overturn but
here if the defense can simply prove the
allegations that they have in their
filings because they have two affidavits
right directly from from jurors and one
from a I heard that there was some sort
of complications to get him in the
affidavit so let's just call it two and
a half three if all those allegations
are true there's a presumption of
prejudice that the prosecution now has
to overcome and that's a tough road to
hoe in the sense that they now have to
show that this was harmless that telling
smokers you're not going to get a break
and maybe that's why they came back in
33 hours telling them all this different
information about forget about this
forget about that he's a liar that that
was harmless I don't think that's going
to be easy for them to prove and that
could have this case reversed can we
talk about Rebecca Hill for a secondary
if all of this is true is she liable
without potentially liable for both
state and federal crimes absolutely
she's in a lot of trouble and in fact
she could have ethics bringing you know
cases against her she could actually
have to go before the Ethics Committee
but I mean worse than that from a
criminal perspective she could go to
jail for 10 years and she could be fined
for misconduct for jury tampering what
she's being accused of doing here what
the petition is stating all of the
affidavits that Ryan is talking about
there are two affidavits there was a
third
affidavit by the law clerk by the
paralegal who actually talked to a third
juror but the point is if in fact Hill
did all the things that are alleged in
these petitions if she said you can't
have smoke breaks if she said you're
going to stay overnight if she
essentially said don't believe Alec
Murdoch she is jury tampering and she
could go to jail real real quick is it
also a violation of federal law because
you're violating his constitutional
rights she's a state actor who's elected
and this would be just similar to like
an officer killing someone in their
private it's a Sixth Amendment right to
an impartial jury it is quite the
allegation we're going to talk a little
bit more about it still ahead on Long
crime daily we're not done talking about
Alec Murdoch's chances for a new trial
we're taking a deep dive into a Facebook
post that eventually led to a juror
being dismissed did that post even
really exist and did Miss Becky
orchestrate it to her own advantage
stay with us
thank you
and welcome back to Long Prime daily
everybody so we're taking a deep dive
into the motion file by Alec Murdoch's
defense team seeking a new trial Murdoch
was convicted convicted of gunning down
his wife and son in South Carolina he
has maintained his innocence but that
motion accuses the clerk of court
Rebecca Hill of improperly tampering
with the jury and even misrepresenting
information to the judge to get a juror
tossed off the case all in a seeming
effort to ensure that Murdoch would be
found guilty we're gonna get into that
second part I want you to stick with me
here because it's a little complicated
so first the day after Alec Murdoch
finished testifying in his own defense
Hill known to many as Miss Becky
reportedly saw a Facebook post that
hinted that one of the jurors might be
talking to people outside the court when
the judge asked to see the post she
couldn't find it but another employee
found an apology posted in its place
that post was from before Murdoch
testified Miss Becky believed that the
post was written by the ex-husband of a
juror she even reportedly went so far as
2 confront that juror alone in her
office accusing her of discussing the
case while with her ex while she was
drunk now the juror denied that saying
she hadn't been or hadn't seen her
husband in 10 years the clerk told the
juror that she had sent law enforcement
to the man's home and he confirmed
everything but a sworn affidavit from
the ex says that never happened that
juror ended up being dismissed and
replaced by an alternate turns out the
apology was posted by someone else with
the same name as the ex the defense
alleges that Miss Becky knew that and
intentionally misled the court Brian
what allegations you know against the
clerk here miss hell I mean what stood
out to you the most about that it was
the fact that the Facebook person we're
talking about is Timothy Stone the
husband similar name goes by Tim Stone
on Facebook the fact that that Timothy
Stone has you can see the picture of him
on his profile and according to the
affidavit from juror 785 she showed a
picture of her ex-husband to the clerk
and let's take a step back this is not a
Clerk's job it's not a Clerk's job to
question a juror as to what they saw
what they didn't see sending officers to
their home to question whether or not
they they tampered or were tampered with
this is outside the realm of what she
should be doing all together this is
supposed to happen as we've all seen in
front of the judge with both parties
there so the fact that this even came up
yet alone the details that we're hearing
is bizarre to me and why she has a job
is beyond me and we should be
reevaluating not only in this case but
every other case she touched I was just
thinking that
um let's say for example Terry Court
says not going to order a new
evidentiary hearing there's no new trial
granted what happens with his appeal you
know I think there will be a new trial
granted but even if that doesn't happen
I think there's a very good chance that
there will be an appeal that is
successful one of the grounds the most
promising is the fact that those
financial crimes were admitted you may
recall that and the judge said look this
is you know 403 you have to show that it
has nothing to do with character it has
to do with motive or plan and that's how
you get it in and the judge agreed that
it should come in because it has to do
with the motive but there was so much
Jesse I mean it was just one crime after
another that it did affect his character
people meaning the jury had to look at
him and say you know something is wrong
with you you are a liar you probably are
lying about you know what happened with
Maggie and Paul and so I I do think they
have a decent ground for appeal there
you know it's interesting to think about
if he is granted a new trial and they
can get a judge a different judge who
maybe will not allow the financial
crimes into evidence then we're dealing
with a whole different ball game